hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code so today we're
going to be solving
leak code 11 container with most water
so we're given an array of heights so
this is a height 1 this is i
8 6 so on and so on and
using these heights we want to see
what's the biggest
area we can form with a container that
has a
left height and a right height so in
this example
you can see that if we take this one
with a height of eight
and this one with a height of seven we
can create an
area let's see how wide this is at one
two three
one two three seven wide and seven tall
so that's seven by seven
and the area is going to be 49 and they
tell us that much
in the explanation so since we're given
a list of heights and we want to
maximize the area
we can potentially just take every
single combination right so check every
left pointer
and every right pointer so my first
thought with this
is what's the brute force way what's the
easiest way to solve this problem
well let's just try every single
combination of left and right let's just
try
every single possible container we could
make
and see if it works so let's say this is
our left
and this is our right what's the most
what's the max area we can make with
this well
let's fill it up to 1 and if we keep
filling
it up with water notice how it's going
to spill to the left right
so this left pointer is our bottleneck
right
we have a height of 1 and we have a
height of seven
the minimum one is one so you know
we can't fill it up any higher the width
of this is also
one so we get a we get an area of one by
one
with water and of course if this one
remains our left pointer we can try this
one as our right pointer
and in this case the width is going to
be two
but the height is still going to be one
our
remember our left height is only one so
our bottleneck is one so we get an area
of two by one
so i'm starting to notice a bit of a
pattern but let's just keep continuing
with the brute force
so next we can try this area
that's going to be three next we can try
this area that's going to be 4.
next we try this one that's going to be
5 and we can just keep going
the height is going to stay 1 because
our left pointer has a height
of 1. next we move our left pointer
here and again we're just going to
continue with the brute force solution
eventually we're going to have our right
pointer set here and then we're going to
find
our result right it's going to be 7 by 7
that's the biggest area we can do and
since we're checking every single
combination we know we're eventually
going to find
the correct solution the only downside
is that this algorithm
is big o of n squared now is that good
enough
i guess it depends on your interviewer
and let me just quickly code up the
solution
for that so this is the brute force of
n solution let's first initialize our
result
which is our area i'm going to
initialize it to 0 because you can't
really have a negative area
at least not in this context and we want
to go through every single combination
so
i'm going to have our left pointer go
through
every single indices of height
so i'm going to get the length of height
which is our
array so left is going to
be at every single position at least
once now
right pointer we can just have this one
be always at least one position ahead of
left so left plus one
because it all our right pointer of
course always needs to be
to the right of our left pointer right
and for each of these
combinations we want to compute the area
so let's do that
area is going to be equal let me just
remember
how to i don't know about you guys but
sometimes even i forget how to compute
the area of a rectangle
so we're going to do width times height
so the width
is going to be right minus left
multiplied by the height now how do we
find the height so how do we find the
height
remember we're focusing on what the
bottleneck is
and by bottleneck in this case we mean
the minimum height because
no matter how tall our right no matter
how tall one of the heights is right
we could extend this to a million but
look how small this one is it's just too
small the water is going to spill out
so we care about the minimum height of
the left and right
pointers so let's get that minimum so
minimum
of height of left
and minimum of height of right
so now that we've computed the area
remember we want the max area so we can
set our result
equal to the max of
itself and of the area that we just
computed
so every time we compute an area if it's
the max we're going to update our result
and now all we need to do is return that
result that we computed
let's see if it works unfortunately it
doesn't work we got time limit exceeded
so
now we need to figure out how we can
make this a little bit better
can we get a linear time solution so now
let's take a look at the
linear time solution the one that will
actually work in late code
so remember how we said that the minimum
height
is our limiting factor we really don't
want
small heights so let's see if we can try
a two pointer technique now i'm gonna
initialize
the left pointer all the way at the left
and i'm going to initialize the right
pointer all the way at the right
why because we want to maximize the area
so
why would i initialize them like
because we want the width to be as big
as possible because if this left height
is super tall and this right height is
super tall
then we've instantly found our result
but of course in this case that doesn't
work we get an
area of 1 by 8 i think so that's
obviously
not the result so what do we do how do
we update our left and right pointers
so the first area that we computed was
an 8 which is
our max because our initial max because
this is basically the maximum so far
so now how are we going to update our
pointer well
we're going to look at what's the
minimum height this one has a height of
one
this one has a height of seven so why
would i shift my right pointer when it
has a height of
seven when i could instead shift my left
pointer
which has a height of one and
potentially increase it
so now left is over here and we have a
height of 8
and lucky for us we've basically found
our solution but i'm just going to keep
going with the algorithm
just to kind of show you how it works so
now we have an
area of seven by seven which we know is
so our max area gets updated our max is
no longer eight it's 49
which we know is the correct solution
next i'm gonna take the minimum
of eight and seven
is smaller so we're going to shift our
right pointer to the left
now our right height is looks like three
so the area that we're going to compute
is going to be 3
by 6
which is 18 but that's too small that's
not bigger than our maximum
so we don't need to update our max area
now our minimum
is 3 so we're going to shift
now we have an 8 by 5 rectangle which is
40 but that's still not greater than 49
and
and now we get to a nice little edge
case where both of the values
are equal in this case it doesn't
actually matter which pointer that we
shift
but if you wanted to you could shift
the one that has a larger height coming
like
for example like this height is at six
whereas this height is at four
we could choose to shift this one just
because we know that a larger height
exists over here
but it actually doesn't matter you could
shift either one
so now our left is six so we get
six by four which is 24 too small
we don't care about it let's just keep
going
so now our minimum height is six let's
shift our left pointer
now we get a two by three rectangle
which is too small
let's shift our left pointer one more
time
hey this time we got a five by two
that's a little better than before but
still not better than our max and so
this is basically the last
rectangle or water container that we can
form
it's going to be four by one and now if
we try to shift our left pointer
we get to the terminating condition we
get to the condition that's going to
end our code so now that we shift our
left pointer
here we're going to get our left here
left and right are at the same
position so let's get rid of this let's
get a solution that can actually work
on leak code and maybe you might need
this solution in your interview if the
brute force is not good enough
so once again i'm going to set our
result equal to zero
i'm going to do what i did in the
explanation our left pointer is going to
be initialized
all the way to the
left which is zero and our right pointer
is going to be initialized all the way
to the right
so these values are zero and length
of heights minus one
and remember our condition for the loop
is while
left is less than right because if
they're equal that's no
good and if they if left passes right
that's no good either
so let's compute the area again i'm just
going to copy and paste it from my above
solution because
that's what the brute force solution is
for right you can learn
the basic problem the basic parts of the
problem before doing
the clever stuff i can also just copy
and paste the part where we update our
result as well
now the part that we have to change
though is
when we're updating our left and right
pointers we're doing it
based on a certain condition if
the height at position left is less than
the height at position
right we're going to shift our left
pointer to the right
we're going to increment our left
pointer because we want to maximize
both of these heights now the other
condition
is the opposite case so if height of
left
was greater than height of right
then we would want to shift our right
pointer and we want to decrement it
and the last case is if they're equal
right that's our else condition
and remember how i said we could do
either one if
uh if they're both equal right we could
increment our left pointer or we could
decrement our
right pointer uh notice how both of
these are doing the same thing
so i'm just going to condense this i'm
just going to get rid of
these two lines of code
now all we need to do is return the
maximum that we computed
let's see if it actually works this time
okay of course i had
a typo so i had a s at the end of
heights
let's run it one more time and this time
it'll work so
this is the actual linear time solution
the big o of n solution
as always thank you so much for watching
like and subscribe if this was helpful
and i'll see you pretty soon
you